that's matt ryan on pft pm a couple of
weeks ago baby man where was that in the
grotto was that in the grotto i mean you
just got so many locations on the
property to do these interviews it's
unbelievable how big is this house whoa
look at the archways the stone is that
that cheap rock from florida are those
real stones that's that's that's the
cheap rock from florida that's actually
new age zebra
i i worked very hard to glue those to
the wall took a lot of work to actually
glue those fake rocks to the wall uh
good internet though we got a little
access point down there so you know it
doesn't get choppy like when i do it in
my office need to get an
access point in there as well but that's
a different story altogether the story
is the atlanta falcons number 19 on our
pre-season power rankings a team that
finished the season
six and two and we always put a star
next to those teams that finished strong
this year
going into the season falcons jets both
riding that six and two wave from the
prior year chris and
uh yeah the the falcons are a team that
i think we're not paying attention to
like we should and i think the falcons
probably like it that way because it's
all about the saints and the buccaneers
the saints and the buccaneers the saints
and the buccaneers let's not forget
about the falcons they still have matt
ryan they still have julio jones they've
got a core of veteran talent
and they showed us down the stretch last
year they can put it together and win
they went to san francisco a game the
49ers needed and upset them right this
is a team that if they can get a few
breaks and if they can stay healthy and
if they can get something out of todd
gurley in the running game this is a
team that could be pretty darn good
agreed i mean health is the big issue
for the falcons the last two years i
mean that's been their their number one
issue but you know when i think of the
falcons right now i mean i'm with you i
think of them as one of those teams that
could be a sleeping giant when all said
and done here when this 2020 season ends
you know i look at you know team like
the falcons we've hit on you know today
the rams the chargers the browns the
broncos those five teams is all teams
where you know we've seen this run where
it's three or four new teams in the
playoffs every year for a bunch of years
in a row now those are the teams i got
my eye on and especially the atlanta
falcons there's just too much talent
across the roster for you not to believe
in them i mean you said it okay yeah
todd gurley we need that running back
position to have a little production
there that's been hurting for atlanta
the last few years offensive line you
know got some young pieces there along
with alex mack who's still one of the
best centers in football trade and get
hayden hurst at tight end you know we've
talked about the two receivers they got
and jones and ridley damn that's about
as good a duo as you're gonna get in
football i mean when you look at that
graphic on tv there and you go gurley
jones ridley hayden hurst i go damn you
know you that that'll compete with
anybody in football as far as your two
receivers tight end and running back go
and you know you've said it they're
sleeping on you know they're under the
radar they're really well coached you
know and they've done the proper things
even on the defensive side of the ball
to help their team out signing a dante
fowler drafting the kid from clemson aj
tyrell in the first round to where i'm
with you mike
don't sleep on the falcons they're one
of those teams i look at and go
i won't be shocked if they win the nfc
south this year i certainly could see
that happening
yeah i absolutely could see it happening
as the saints and the buccaneers are so
concerned about each other the falcons
just kind of sneak up on the outside if
they can't stay healthy any of todd
gurley can be anything like he was right
a couple of years ago before that knee
just got to the point where it no longer
would cooperate and everything has been
great so far of course we're in the time
of the year where everyone's in the best
shape of their lives but todd gurley has
had a lot to overcome with that knee it
goes back to the torn how he suffered
2014-ish at georgia and look it didn't
stop him from being the premier
offensive player in the nfl in 2017 but
something has happened the past two
seasons falcons hoping they can turn
that around mentioned julio jones calvin
ridley that this this is an exciting
offense potentially and you know you've
got the head coach who's been there for
a while now and dan quinn you've got
dirk cutter the offensive coordinator
who was the former bucks head coach
you've got raheem wars uh more rather
the the uh
morris you're right the defensive
coordinator who used to be the
buccaneers head coach you got two former
buccaneers coach
as your coordinators uh and uh it's you
look there's a lot of experience there
there's a lot of wisdom there and you
know matt ryan in year number 13 we talk
all the time about guys like brady and
brees who have seen it all matt ryan's
seen a lot too definitely and he's
getting to the point where you can't
fool him i i just think that we need to
be paying more attention to the falcons
than we are
uh because they're a team that that you
know we get to october november we could
be saying oh my gosh
uh yeah why weren't we paying more
attention to the falco oh no no doubt
yeah i mean you know we just we talked
about the injuries last year killed
their football team the todd gurley
factor is real i feel like dan quinn's
got his little formula for coaching the
team down you know you could say what
you want about the falcons you know i
don't always sit there and go oh my gosh
it's the most creative schemes i've
never seen anything like this in my life
no i don't sit there and do that but
they got everything and the one thing
i'll say about dan quinn and that team
they compete they're tough even when
they're down to like fifth stringers
playing i mean they throw their bodies
around so he has a team that believes in
him and his coaching style and when you
have that
with talent you know grady jarrod dante
fowler jr on the edge dion jones keanu
neil who is a guy that if it can stay
healthy will be in the derwen james
jamal adams conversation the damn guy
just can't stay healthy healthy and i
hope that happens but you know you hit
on rahim morris i was in tampa with
raheem morris all those years this
seattle scheme that the falcons play
because dan quinn's from the seattle
seahawks it all originated down there in
tampa bay
pete carroll he used to come down there
and visit rahim morris and monty kiffin
and all those guys and raheem morris
understands this defense let alone has a
great way of leading men
you know
his one of his good friends and his
biggest mentor in his life was mike
tomlin and they have a similar style
where they can communicate and get guys
to run through a wall and not even think
twice about it and that's where i'm
excited about the falcons between that
the talent you talk about matt ryan i
think he's played phenomenal football
the last few years they're dangerous
and it's good to see rahim morris
getting this opportunity i think he got
thrust into a coaching job head coaching
job sooner than he should have yeah and
it was that strange palace coup where
john gruden and bruce allen get thrown
out and then and then raheem morris and
mark dominic get installed just like
that there was just always a weird vibe
there and it didn't work out in tampa
and like tampa not nearly among the most
patient of teams when it comes to
keeping coaches
it it'd be good to see
rahim get another opportunity and you
know what let's be realistic one
opportunity could come as interim head
coach if this team doesn't do what it
needs to do there was a strong sense
last year one and seven into the bye
week that dan quinn was done he managed
to stick around chris i feel like going
into the year
he's gonna have that that flag is one of
the guys who needs to do something
positive this season or he's not gonna
be back for 2021. i i would agree you
know i i think the you know the big
problem is is some of the headline
talent they got on the team there's
going to be expectations there
so
yes i i would now what is that number
you know as far as wins and losses that
might cost him his job but you're right
there's a little bit of a a target on
him for per se he's one of those guys
where you go ooh if they end up six and
ten
you know it's it's done you know if they
go eight and eight does he salvage his
job i don't know that'll be you know
that's a tough one certainly but you
know i look at this team and go
they have a high ceiling and i don't see
that low of a floor you know mike where
where are you at ceiling wise
i could say ceiling wise best case
scenario they win the nfc south they're
12 and four and they're one of the top
two seeds in the nfc which it doesn't
matter to be the top two seeds anymore
you just want to be the top one but
either way a one or a two seed i think
it's the ceiling you would you up there
in that thought
look did we expect them to be the one
seed the year in 2016 when they made it
to the super bowl we kind of felt and
they were the two seed that years on
that team yeah they had the they had the
opportunities remember they were the one
seed in 2010 when aaron rodgers and
company went in there and just plastered
them on a saturday night in the division
around and they they had that thing with
blown leads and yeah and uh yeah they
get to the super and then we're blown
lead in the super bowl but we didn't
expect them to be in the super bowl that
year so you know we we
this is one of the challenges of any nfl
season we are so influenced by what
happened last year that kind of the
fumes of last year spill into this year
definitely and and we and we can't set
aside you know that even though we know
that the turnover is going to be about
50 even though we are well aware of that
as the postseason field churns every
year we just can't bring ourselves
to to say yeah you know what this team
isn't just going to be a playoff team
this is a team that's got the potential
to be one of the top teams and do the
falcons have a chance to be one of the
top teams i mean did we expect the 49ers
to be the one seed last year at this
time right so yeah if it falls their way
and that's the one thing that no one can
predict injuries breaks bad calls good
calls there are so many little things
that define your season you know that
key third and seven stopping that team
on fourth and two from the three yard
line just one move here one move there
changes everything for a team and the
falcons are good enough to be in the
position where they can benefit from
those breaks that no one can control
yeah and get to the top seed if it all
falls their way yeah they are they're
they're you know the the thing is though
that like you said they're a little
top-heavy and they have not been able to
withstand the injury storm the last two
years and the last two years also you
know one of their mottos has to be
start fast you know
ever since that super bowl year
you know 2017 yeah okay they got to the
playoffs 10 and six almost beat the
eagles in that divisional round game had
the ball you know but 2018 2019 got to
such slow starts they were playing
behind the eight ball from the get-go
you know so that's got to be a part of
their conversation this year and
especially with their schedule earlier
this year i mean seattle
dallas the green bay packers you know
three to your first four games bears is
gonna be no cupcake either you know
that's real so they better hit the game
the ground running and you know mike
you're right with like the that really
does jump out to me you know you talk
about like the 50 turnover that's where
it stinks with no preseason football not
that you can always gauge a ton from
preseason football but those last few
years i've worked with you we put our
you know finger on two or three teams
ago they look different this preseason
they look determined they're playing
very physical for a preseason game and
it usually correlates to oh damn they're
playing pretty good in the regular
season we're not going to have that this
year and i think that's going to make it
to be a you know more of a guessing game
than ever for guys like you and me
and a very interesting september as we
start to hash out who really does look
like they're putting it together and who
knows
maybe no preseason is going to be very
bad for the seahawks and very good for
the falcons and we're going to find out
when those two teams meet week one all
right let's take a break so much talk
about what's going to happen with
college football season we didn't draft
on friday the things that we miss about
a normal nfl preseason we're going to do
a draft today of the things we would
miss if college football season doesn't
happen that's next here on pro football
talk
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports